It can't be easy for George Lucas to sit back
and watch other filmmakers guide the Star
Wars galaxy.
Of course, it's hard to know for sure because
he doesn't seem to say a lot on the subject
lately.
Lucas has not been directly involved in the
franchise since it was sold to Disney in 2012,
but he seems to approve of the direction,
even if his words on the subject are few and
far between.
Back when The Force Awakens arrived, Lucas
told Vulture that:
… "fans are going to love it"...
and that it was:
"very much the kind of movie they’ve been
looking for."
Some perceived his word choice as a backhanded
compliment, but he had a similar response
to Rogue One, as director Gareth Edwards said
in a press conference that Lucas "really liked"
the anthology flick.
And just days ahead of the release of The
Last Jedi, too, the originator of the Star
Wars universe had a similar reaction to the
flick written and directed by Rian Johnson
-- with his representatives telling The Hollywood
Reporter that he thought the movie was "beautifully
made," and that he was "complimentary" to
Johnson after seeing it.
Johnson had previously said that while he
was attempting to pursue his own vision of
the story, he wanted it to still be something
that would satisfy long-time fans by offering:
"Some things we haven't seen in Star Wars
before.
And hopefully it still feels like a Star Wars
movie, that's the number one thing."
For Johnson, making a Star Wars movie meant
keeping it light-hearted, despite the intensity.
"I think, I hope fans are gonna be pleasantly
surprised by how fun and funny this movie
is."
As of now, The Last Jedi has a 93 percent
fresh rating on Rotten Tomatoes, which makes
it the best-rated Star Wars flick on the aggregator.
And while some viewers have knocked the movie's
audience score down to well below that figure,
it's clear The Last Jedi has at least offered
enough suspense and surprises to satisfy those
who matter most, including George Lucas.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!